we are already in a society where the
idea of men being Breadwinners is not
because men can't I don't you can't
don't bring that up dude oh don't bring
it up cool I don't like that I don't
like that argument what I don't
understand down the middle that's it
what you make us look wrong
[Music]
all right so
this is an MIB [__] and we've kind of
talked about this topic before but this
is a very very recent one and I got a
lot of uh attraction and attention and
we also have Jimmy eating over here and
he's always given great relationship
advice and things like that especially
on how to flirt so we're gonna bring a
topic like this back into the game right
this is an am I the [__] for not
wanting to split expenses proportional
to income
she says I live with my boyfriend in
flat he owns fully paid off his father
gave it to him that's important detail
the whole building was built six years
ago and it's in a very popular area
I pay my boyfriend half of the market
rate rent which we update every year by
looking how much the flats are being
rented out in the building complex which
is a lot of money but I agreed to it
other than this we did everything else
50 50 in the past so again he didn't buy
his house his dad gave it to him it's
fully paid off but she still pays 50
percent
why oh that's kind of weird yeah wait so
he's not he there's no mortgage that he
has to pay or anything but she's paying
it's a flat he owns yeah yeah they're
the UK for sure huh so he basically like
estimated himself she's looking at
market rate she's looking at market rate
based off of the like neighborhood she's
trying to be fair yeah she's being fair
is it one of those where he never asked
she's just paying or he asked and she's
paying uh it didn't say specifically on
that detail yeah but that sounds weird
because if it's if he never asked if he
never asked and she's just paying that
she just wants to be like a boss [__]
and I can I get that too but if he's
asking then he's a a f word
she's a cigarette as the UK she says
again I pay my boyfriend half of the
market rate rent which we update every
year by looking how much the flats are
being rented out for in the building
complex which is a lot of money but I
agreed to it so maybe they had a joint
conversation about it in some way that
just sounds so weird to me it's weird
that she's paying him for something he
was given and we're not we're not even
at the end of the [__] party okay
keep going she says I got a new job with
a significant pay increase and now my
boyfriend says we should start splitting
expenses proportional to income because
that's fair whoa wait what what kind of
communist [__] is that yeah
yo if this [__] cup of coffee costs
two bucks but you make a hundred grand I
make 50 Grand does that mean I'd pay
like 50 cents and you pay 150.
that's [__] [__] dude there's a
lot of math too he's like when I [__]
bust nuts in your [__] you make more so
you pay for the condom pay for the
condom proportional to income yeah no
that's weird she says I told him I don't
think it's fair that I should start
paying for more just because I got a new
job and nothing else changed I already
pay him rent enough rent that would get
me the same size flat a few streets away
so it's more than fair to him he made
some in my opinion very weak arguments
and accused me of ripping them off
that's when I told him that under no
circumstances we will split expenses
proportional to income [__] she says now
that I've calmed down a bit I'm worried
whether or not I'm wrong especially
since my best friend told me that this
is how they do it with her boyfriend too
and whoa my boyfriend owning the flat is
irrelevant they both they both like
[__] that's what they like get out of
there they're saying flat it doesn't say
location yes but out of there dude wait
so but she's saying that it's common
because her friend does the same [__]
too well that sample size of one person
it's definitely not a common well okay
I'm pretty sure us being Asian has a
little bit of something like to do with
it because I don't really think this is
no normal even for Asian Americans to
think in this light
even though we're western-ish right like
just it I can't get myself to do that
yeah I agree I mean the thing is they're
like the hard part is they're like
boyfriend and girlfriend exactly and
that comes with all sorts of uh like
where in your relationship are you and
the minute you start nickel and diming
stuff it kind of wears it puts a wear on
the Romantic part of it yeah like
whatever happened to just half dude
there's a close generator I have a
question so do you think this is a
double so she's the one making more
right now she is so do you think it's a
double standard where it's like if the
guy is making more he's paying the
majority of the rent and that's fine I
think it's weird on either side that
there's this fluctuation of like expense
exchange yeah versus like let's just go
down the middle like if we're both gonna
use toilet paper if we're either way
someone pays for 100 or just do 50 50.
yeah
versus like every what's the market
value of this this is way more this year
than last year and you got paid you know
it's like it's like how how much of a
spreadsheet do you want to pull out
every time you talk about enter your
point though I think the double standard
isn't in that I think it comes from like
again like right women like have to bear
children and stuff like that so we are
already in a society where the idea of
men being Breadwinners is not because
men can't I don't you can't don't bring
that up dude oh don't bring it up cool I
don't like that I don't like that
argument what I don't understand down
the middle that's it
what you made us look wrong the way that
he's charging her doesn't even exist in
business so for example uh like if I
sell Nick these uh pairs of sunglasses
right I would love to buy those let's
like yeah let's say it's 25 bucks for
you Nick but because Bart makes more
it's actually 45 for him that's true but
oh but I'll pay uh but Nick can buy it
for 25 because you know he doesn't work
that way in Texas that does work in
business with health insurance as well
but the model is so different though you
get more things though no like for
example even like Covered California
when you put in your income if you put
in a high income they charge that's
because you're in California
you get you yeah whatever you pay is
based on like how much Services you get
yeah so then for me that's like if it
doesn't even exist out
relationship
basically doing something that's
unorthodox I agree with the relationship
element of that but I also see that
there are like instances at which if you
make more you pay more and but not in
relationship terms so I understand that
yeah well you make more you pay more I
think that depends on the situation so
for example
um let's say like in my situation I make
more I pay more but that doesn't devalue
her or I don't expect her to come up so
for for example like let's say
um Hannah does make money right but the
value that she brings to the
relationship is much more if she helped
me out in other things for like maybe
domestic work right and that might be
devalued but think about it dollar for
dollar if I decided to hire a maid if I
decided to hire uh cleaners uh wash and
fold service all of the things I'm gonna
jack you off yeah basically if you put
that's expensive a thousand dollars so
if I put that in dollar amounts what if
it actually equals to be a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year in
Services right and then so if I'm
expecting her to go out and get like a
80 000 job it actually makes more sense
for her to the to do the equivalent of a
hundred fifty thousand dollars in
domestic Services you know what I mean
so like to me I'm gonna tell a jackoffs
but that's some but basically I'm
thinking about the value so if you think
about value and and value exchange so
like it's not like someone's sitting on
their ass all day and saying like
[__] take care of me right right like
but not everything is about dollar for
dollar right so like if one person earns
less or more there's other things you
can do to bring value into the
relationship and balance it out
do you expect hypo again not necessarily
your hand but just like the hypothetical
though of a partner to be cognizant that
if somebody is more of a breadwinner
proportionally that even though they may
not be expected to like contribute more
financially maybe they should contribute
more in other like dollar for you know
is that like an expectation I think as a
team whether I'm in a relationship in a
marriage or relationship in a in a
friendship or like any of those aspects
right I think that every member should
be trying their best to bring value for
each other as a team yeah and it's not
about dollar value so for example we're
business partners right and we have
different strengths as as different uh
business partners but we also have
different times in our lives when one of
us need help because the other one can't
be there and for me if it's like me and
Bart are business partners and we're
thinking about staying in this business
for over a decade
so what if year two
um he has something else that that's
gonna make him really busy and you can't
attend to this partnership that's fine
because in year three maybe that might
happen to me and he'll step in right so
there's different exchanges that you
just trust your partner to give their
full force and to back you up but but to
that point though in business there's
certain things that that maybe Bart can
do then you have to hire out somebody
else to do in a relationship you can't
hire somebody else right it can't hire a
blow job right exactly my girl doesn't
give me a [__]
across town true right I I think the
weird part in this is they had an
arrangement and then she starts making
more I think if she wants to contribute
more that's on her but for him to go it
was in your purse over there that's the
weird part that's the for me yeah like
that whole like mindset moving the goal
posts yeah that's that part is is weird
what if uh what if again just
hypotheticals for the same conversation
especially if he's the one with the
upper hand like he he is like let's say
if he was their their Arrangement is
he's like this uh struggling actor
um he has to you know work two jobs to
make ends meet and he's really trying to
like work on his grind and she's been
supporting him if he needs extra help I
understand that that's the whole team
part right hey can you pay for more of
this I got to pay for more acting
classes but their their goal is Let's
help build this guy up yeah this guy
already got a free pad yeah he has a
free pad free rent and he's still
peeking into his purse that's the part
I'm like what the [__] it's [__]
weird that part's weird yeah and on top
of that too it's like how much more
money is she making than him to the
point and does the money she's paying
for the rent get included in his income
yeah because he's being paid yeah yeah
yeah it's weird that would be definitely
the biggest thing I think what if what
if you were to potentially take that
fact out what if I didn't read that part
and it was just a matter of like things
are 50 50 but then uh somebody in the
guy or girl somebody likes had a
significantly a larger pay increase or
something like that you know what I'm
saying I think then you probably have to
take into account like team goals right
like yeah that's different I think it
depends on your partner's spending
habits so for example right like in most
of my relationships I never had to look
at the spending habits and say like
that's pretty [__] excessive or weird
or whatever
and I've never got that
um
in most cases right like it always came
from a a concerned Place rather than a
judgmental place so I don't know if I
can relate in this way but I think like
there are a lot of relationships where
they don't openly discuss finance and
this one it sounds so specific that it's
so [__] weird
but I think most people avoid it
altogether until it's too late and then
and then you have couples like this
that's like nickel and diming every
[__] piece and then so it's like how
do you find the Middle where this seems
like average and moderate and normal
I don't know because like I've been
lucky enough to where all of my
relationships I never fought over this
[__] because it was it was like you're
getting with like-minded people that
spend similar lifestyle wise like yeah
yeah because like let's say you're
really into buying luxury shoes and your
girl was like not even in that stuff
into that stuff right and you have a
shared account and if you're struggling
and you're out here buying luxury shoes
all day she's gonna be like what the
[__] is wrong with you we need to buy
groceries but in this case I just don't
hear any struggle of like why he should
be saying I need more money yeah why
what does he need the money for like and
I don't know they're not married so like
I feel like the way like me and Giro did
in the beginning was like the easiest
like from day one but there's three bank
accounts mine hers and then our expense
in the middle because in the beginning
when we're doing JK we're struggling
hardcore she's working at Bank of
America so she's like a corporate woman
so she's already making more and we just
put money 50 50 into this in our expense
account that pays for rent groceries
whatever and so if she's making more and
she wants to ball out get a beamer she
can if she wants to buy a person she can
and whatever money I'm making on on my
own that's our own so we just
everything's just in this account that
goes 50 50 and if she makes more she
could buy her own toys and if I make
more by our own toys and it's been like
that since since now yeah so we do it
too so now we just have we still have
that same exact expense account that we
both put money in that pays for now it's
all of our expenses plus type of stuff
because he's 50 50. so so every month
it's uh it's a percentage or a certain
amount it's a certain amount so before I
would when in the beginning it was like
500 bucks each person and that covers
like whatever and then as our expenses
grew then it was more and more and more
but you guys also helped each other out
in so many ways like that doesn't even
that you're not keeping track of like
how many hours also with Geo dedicating
to our business yeah that she's helped
build yeah and she never kept track
right so this is the nature of like I
think our friendship and relationship
and the people we're around is that it's
kind of so foreign to me of checking and
keeping track because we're all building
together yeah like you guys came in the
other day and you did the the podcast on
your own because we're trying out a new
format but they didn't go hey guys if we
do this can you give us like this much
dollars oh you didn't send the invoice
you should have you shut up I was
actually going to send you an invoice
for turning the lights on because that's
what oh that's Canon that's Cam for sure
that's canned but definitely that's
funny it's because I think what the
difference might be is just we're all
like uh
self-employed right so you it turns into
a different mentality of like just put
in work and some of this might pay off
some of it might not right but you know
you all gotta try yeah and then so if
you're in a relationship with a person
that understands that they see this
teamwork as like let's put in this
effort together let's build this family
let's do this stuff and who knows it
might work it might not work whatever
um because actually Hannah her friends
are telling her like you haven't
um signed any paperwork for the business
you've been helping out their business
you've been doing this stuff uh what if
like all this stuff happens and all of a
sudden like you don't see any of those
things and she goes like oh well I'm
confident in my own skills to where
after this I can build my own now I can
run a restaurant now I can do whatever
so I'm like it also the skills that she
values were all the things that we've
built in the experience that we did
during with building of jumbee and all
this stuff and then so she's like like
maybe it's the difference of people that
work a salary job everything is more
clear-cut because it's easier if you
have a 3 000 a month coming every month
it's so much easier to divvy up that and
then like saying this is your budget
this is whatever
whereas like people that are building a
mom-and-pop shop it's like we don't know
if tomorrow it's going to be a million
dollars or we're in debt for a million
dollars yeah yeah that's true like mine
in this I think is a key like you were
saying yeah like it's just a
like-mindedness that makes this work and
we're not always nickel and diming each
other yeah they need to break up they
need to break up for sure but I mean in
your situation right you have a business
with your girl and then like
how do you break that down and you live
together and you do you know like does
she go well actually you spent 29 days
in my apartment this whole month so like
you know like that's the weird part we
do the same thing like like you do like
I have my account smack has hers with
whatever millions are in there and then
we have our joint
we have our joint account which is like
if there's something we both agree that
we want to do it comes out of that if
there's stuff I want from me comes out
of mind if there's stuff she wants for
hers and it's very simple that way yeah
like I gotta convince Jill that the guns
are for house protection so it comes
from the join account
no she should pay for that yeah
I mean it's for the house
[Music]
foreign